all right so after tim shot the podcast
we hung out
and he left and then david came
yesterday
talking about your kid oh okay kids
don't know their body at all at all
literally right when we're at the
bathroom
you need to go potty oh so defiant
10 minutes later nightmare five minutes
later
i know we're halfway through this trail
at the [ __ ] fireman carry this ass as
it feels like a war casualty
ran to the truck
grabbed the wet wipes
went to the bathroom
safe and sound clean but
came back over here
oh my god
so good thing we didn't have a accident
because i would have been super bad and
then we got mario
and tyka in the back
and as we're coming back up this trail
we're drinking on a hike we see a bunch
of cars come up this road and we're like
oh [ __ ] it's an off-road trail
so you know we got to do got to get in
the car
put the truck to use
and see if you can see some cooler stuff
it was supposed to be exercise but i
like it did you see the uh the jeep
rubicon that came up here the black one
no that thing was so sick it was sick
a honda element would rip
out
come
what are you gonna fix up your forehead
and go off-roading together i am so next
year i i know how to do it i was telling
mark because uh joe actually inspired my
my uh
build that i'm gonna do for the former
so i wanted to look like the 1987 land
cruiser yeah that's a very specific
paint color it's like a silver blue
and i want to get um
silver i actually already have the
silver trd ribs yeah but i'm just going
to put gold caps on it so it mimics the
exact way that it looks that's sick so
super hyped about that but you get a
little lift on it
big ass lift big ass i've been watching
a lot of off-road uh
videos yeah you cannot do these trails
without a lift you can stop the media
you'll get stuck yeah
like yo your axle will go over a big
rock and then you're stuck there the
wheels are turning and they're like oh
[ __ ] that's also why it's good to have
buddies and you can like tie each other
up and in the coaching they're out there
because they have so many aftermarket
parts yeah on top of that i've been
watching a lot of comparison videos yeah
even i like performance wise the 4runner
was meeting like even the new bronco
after they did and this is i think it
was just the stock
uh trd probe
i'm actually a fan of the
broncos and the ones that the one that's
decked out yeah it's like 60 something
thousand dollars when you can get a four
runner get a used one yeah upgrade it to
whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah i mean
like
yeah why not there's this uh ig page you
have to follow i think it's either
called like
terrorist toyota or or toyota's of war
and uh
it's all so you know terrorists are
reliable vehicles
so they have all of these like tacomas
forerunners all with missile launchers
and stuff on the back
all out through afghanistan because in
order to cause terror and like a
reliable state you need a reliable car
so it's all these toyotas that'll hook
the [ __ ] up but with like weaponry
[Music]
look at this drawer system look at this
drawer maybe you'll be different from
geo cause you don't care but look at
this sick drawer system look at this
look at all this storage
isn't that sick that's pretty cool it's
awesome that's so organic hey she likes
it did you get scolded
that's cool huh you can put like and all
these come color coded so you get red
blue yellow whatever and you could put
like your hunting one in a box or you're
fishing one in a box or if it's harder
for one in a box what if you have stuff
that's bigger than this size you're
asking bad questions
that's what that's that's what the back
of the truck's for
yeah the deficit isn't too high though
no it's perfect okay you can still put
stuff there sponsored all right i got a
sponsor
we got sponsor right so so ergonomically
organized
ergonomically again
look at that off-road pedals and a
little pink little jeepety-g's owls
there are little off-road pedals i do
boy
or something
hey what the hell i do boy hey chump
yeah this is rocky up here why are you
making that noise
[Music]
my titties are jiggling like crazy
you should wear a bra dude i would but i
free the nipple now dude
uh i think i'm sweating more from
driving than i was from
yeah me too actually why are you making
that noise
are you okay
monkey i'm talking to you are you okay
you're a troll oh that's [ __ ] true
control it whoa
[ __ ]
[Applause]
so with the side of the park truck over
here this is the the first turnout that
we saw
i don't know when the next turnout's
going to be so i don't know if i'm going
to be able to do a u-turn and go back
home so i'm parking it over here in the
woods
and uh
we're gonna do our hike
and then when i come back down i can
just pull it down this way
spaghetti carbonara
what is that like
polenta it's basically grits it's
delicious
and then picasso french toast
back at our favorite italian restaurant
in vegas um and this is a brand new menu
so i'm really excited
because it's uh we're coming here for
breakfast slash brunch so there's lunch
menu items i've never seen a brunch menu
i've never seen and oh my god look at
that
oh
bro
spaghetti habanero
all right so we had to order dessert
because everything was so good
from the spaghetti carbonara to the
kachoi pepe pizza to the smoked salmon
pizza to margarita pizza to the polenta
like we cleared everything look at that
thank you are you done the french toast
so i had to order the cinnamon roll look
at this
the juice
and then the
oh
cream
it's so beautiful i know i don't mostly
want to touch it suddenly i speak it
italian
he does what he did
oh it does right
this is a giant cinnamon bun cream looks
so good
can we get one for tyka too
take a little bite if i wanna i wanna
see what i wanna see uh your facial
expressions
that's like the size
it's cinnamon roll dude okay
hurry up the creek
the big one
we got the frosting the frosting
frosting
oh
one of the things that i think a lot of
restaurants mess up they feel they have
to reinvent the wheel for things that
don't need to be reinvented yeah but
when they hit the mark like this they
think everything that maybe some people
don't like about a cinnamon bun right
sometimes they're like it's too dense
sometimes it's too chewy
they made this very light area they kind
of made it a lot more presentable
and elevated a little better but it
still has like the same taste that you
love oh a lot of cinnamon buns
this is so [ __ ] good
you sound like you've been on a food
show i know if you haven't you should be
hire this man
hey david can you check the mic because
yesterday we had tim
so it might be really low so see if it's
like under your chin or not
okay perfect
all right cool let me check the camera
i know
the food was so bomb earlier
welcome everybody to
table talk my name is
we're gonna talk about what's wrong with
this country
first of all there's too many mexicans
coming through our borders dude i know
you're talking about
very funny i know
is that the highest the tallest you're
gonna sit
probably okay perfect
don't judge me david's actually really
good with cameras
and studio stuff
i'm just trying to figure [ __ ] out so
i'm trying to make it look good and it's
like david's looking at me
judgmental korean eyes
look at this oh my god man these [ __ ]
mics
crap
hey that's messed up dude try our best
got a big
chimera just go ahead and floodlight it
out very good soft lighting you got your
little background light so you can go
and outline our bodies a little a little
top light i like it
would have preferred uh
i don't know i'm george now from tiger
valley
you know just up but you know we kind of
get a little key light here maybe you'll
feel like you're the uh yeah it'd be
good
all right so i found these
random pills
on the counter
child uh within my child's reach i
wonder who they belong to
ahem
excuse me
what the [ __ ] is this i just it's too
lazy so i put it into a club
where did you even get this girl from
it's when i make kimchi
okay you left this on the kitchen
counter
okay so why are you touching my
medication because my child could
consume this well then he would just
have immunity towards kobe
tiger do you want something but why is
it like this huh because listen why
don't you get a senior citizen pill
container like everyone
have two cases else's them you have two
cases of that okay get them get them
get them show me your jiu-jitsu
yeah get it get it get jiu-jitsu get it
get him get him show me your jiu-jitsu
north south i get it
oh he's hurting me monkey help me
david's hurting mama
oh my god
theo's hurting mama we gotta do
something about it
[Music]
[Applause]
i just dropped off david and muriel at
the airport
what a fun weekend that was right guys i
got to hang out with tim
hang out with david and shot two brand
new episodes for our new podcast get
close so make sure you subscribe the
link will be down below it is a brand
new podcast i guess a rewrap of the old
podcast with me and jill and we're
bringing on all kinds of super dope
guests and we're launching november 8th
okay november 8th remember that date
make sure you follow us
on youtube on our new channel as well as
follow us on itunes and we have a lot of
dope guests lined up and we're going to
get personal we're going to get deep and
we're gonna get close and that's the
whole point of the podcast and i can't
wait to share all these episodes with
you guys and have a good night good
night